Guys, I will quickly break down the trade that was sent out in the discord, so let's go to the weekly timeframe first. And on the weekly, what I saw was that we took out external liquidity here. And I also saw the internal liquidity down there. Now, once price took out the external, I just dropped down to the 4 hours timeframe. And from here ombuds, what I was looking for was,
a market structure shift. And just around here we got the shift in the market structure.
Now from here onwards, which you can see is that we had this auto block here, like that.
Price came back into our auto block. We did get our entry here, right? But as you can see,
see we have this consolidation phase here.
So I looked at the market maker model here
and also the internal look at it was still there.
And this was the only PD array that I had in my mind
because this is a clean auto block.
So and we also had these equal highs around this level.
So this was a very hyperability setup.
Now once price came back into where auto block,
simply drop down to 15 minutes time from now price came into our auto block so now
I looked at the economic calendar and today was the news at 830 so I would be
taking my trades after 830 so over here we had a market structure shift but
considering the fact that considering the Asian session trading strategy you
can see that the Asian high was still there so this is basically a
So you cannot take a shot position because price will take out the high or low.
So what happened? Price took out the high.
Then we had a shift in the market structure around here.
And we had this clean autoblog.
Now this is when the news even occurred at 8.30.
We took our entry at around 8.45 and boom, look at that.
The price just went down like that.